wir haken uns unter wir lösen die
Probleme unseres Landes gemeinsam so
Bundeskanzler Scholz heute Abend nach
der Konferenz mit den
Ministerpräsidenten Bund und Länder
zeigten sich fast ungewohnt schnell
einig und präsentierten ein
umfangreiches Paket um Bürger in diesem
Winter finanziell zu unterstützen
Entlastung für die hohen Gas- und
Strompreise mit dem Anreiz aber auch
Energie zu sparen und die Nachfolge für
das 9-euro-ticket das dann 49 Euro
kosten wird Krisentreffen im Kanzleramt
wer wird entlastet unser Thema heute in
der phönix-runde
schönen guten Abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin und das sind meine
Gäste Kerstin Andreas bei uns
Vorsitzender der Hauptgeschäftsführung
des Bundesverbands der Energie und
Wasserwirtschaft die das umsetzen muss
was heute beschlossen worden ist
Professor Henning vöpel Volkswirt
Vorstand des Zentrums für europäische
Politik herzlich willkommen Dr Thomas
Engelke er ist Teamleiter Energie und
bauen beim Verbraucherzentrale
Bundesverband und Julia Löhr ist bei uns
wirtschaftskorrespondentin im
hauptstadtbüro der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung ja es ging schneller
als erwartet Frau Löhrmann hat einen
ganzen Tag über gehört es dauert lange
und die werden sich nicht einigen weil
man sich nämlich am 4 Oktober wie gar
nicht einig wurde ist es jetzt ein gutes
Zeichen naja es ist zumindest eine
Erfolg das anders als die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz anfangen
Oktober ist jetzt relativ schnell ging
und wir kurz nach 19 Uhr einen
beschlussspapier hatten aber viele
Details über die in den vergangenen
Tagen schon sehr hitzig diskutiert wurde
sind nach wie vor nicht geklärt da wurde
jetzt weitere Redebedarf angemeldet und
ob das alles so unkompliziert ablaufen
wird wie der Bundeskanzler das in der PK
hinterher versprochen hat da würde ich
auch noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter
setzen also das kann auch gut sein dass
das statt das doppelwumms das Chaos hoch
3 anfangen Dezember gibt der
Bundeskanzler hat ja auch gesagt Herr
Völkl you never walk alone also wir
kümmern uns ist das die Botschaft die
heute auch daraus können kann der Bürger
sicher sein Okay in diesem Winter da
hilft mir der Staat ja das ist erstmal
das das positive Signal glaube ich es
kommt diese Hilfe das geht auch darum
Erwartungen zu stabilisieren durch
diesen Winter zu kommen aber ehrlich
gesagt ist das natürlich der leichteste
Punkt der Politik ist erstmal Entlastung
zu schaffen aber wir reden natürlich
auch über den Winter 23 24 das heißt wir
müssen auch
einsparanreize setzen und das ist
sozusagen ein bisschen ins nächste Jahr
verschoben worden also so ganz rund ist
das Paket noch nicht im Sinne des
Problems ich finde interessant dass wir
im Grunde Krisen immer auf diese Art und
Weise lösen dass wir viel Geld in die
Hand nehmen und sagen wie können wir das
angemessen verteilen aber ich glaube es
ist im Sinne des Problems noch keine
echte Lösung also sie werden das wissen
Frauen Dreh Smart Metering in
Deutschland irgendwie auf dem letzten
Platz das würde uns helfen tatsächlich
Nachfrage Management sozusagen beim
Energieverbrauch zu verbessern auch
sozusagen angebotsseitig über
Alternativen nachzudenken und das fehlt
mir so ein bisschen also wir denken die
Detail das werden die Details aber mir
fehlt sozusagen die Fantasie der Politik
also wir reden immer gleich über Krisen
wir lösen Sie immer auf die ähnliche Art
und Weise wenn ihm viel Geld in die Hand
dann heißt es Wurst oder doppelwurms
aber wir wollen ja sozusagen Fortschritt
generieren und und da sehe ich nicht und
von diesem Hintergrund ist es eher
enttäuschend dass wir nicht in der Lage
sind echte Lösungen für ein reales
Problem zu finden Herr Engelke 200
Milliarden ist ja erstmal viel Geld was
in die Hand genommen da könnten doch
alle Bürger jetzt eigentlich sagen super
der Start der kümmert sich der sorgt
sich ist das für sie auch die Botschaft
die angekommen ist also auf alle Fälle
ist es gut dass Bund und lernen sich
heute geeinigt haben 200 Milliarden Euro
ist sehr viel Geld
wir erleben in den Beratungszentren der
Verbraucherzentrale andauernd die
Personen die zu dem Beratern kommen die
haben unheimlich viel zu tun es kommt
viel mehr als im letzten Jahr und es
kommen natürlich die die nicht mehr
wissen wie sie die Rechnungen bezahlen
sollen und wir haben spezielle im
Gasbereich wir haben Steigerungen
vergleicht im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
von 100% von 200% von 500 Prozent so und
da wissen tatsächlich viele nicht mehr
wie sieht das bezahlen sollen deswegen
brauchen wir die Hilfe jetzt und
deswegen ist es auch gut dass jetzt eine
Entlastung kommt im Dezember und auch im
nächsten Jahr und glauben Sie dass die
Bürger verstanden haben was jetzt genau
kommt
die Lösung ist kompliziert und es wird
ganz wichtig sein dass das nicht nur
heute kommuniziert wird sondern auch in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
wiederholt wird also soll eine
gaspreisbremse geben und eine
strompreisbremse strompreisbremse ab
Januar gaspreisbremse dann ab März
rückwirkend ab Februar aber sie sind die
energiespezialistin Frau Anrede also
heute haben viele gesagt das ist
kompliziert und sie sagen ja eigentlich
schaffen wir das gar nicht wir können
das gar nicht umsetzen was sagen sie
denn jetzt den ganzen Gaskunden wann
gibt es das Geld
also die eine Maßnahme die beschlossen
wurde wo wir auch sagen das funktioniert
ist dass die Abschlagszahlung im
Dezember nicht geleistet werden muss das
ist keine Einmalzahlung an die Menschen
aber es wird einen Teil oder einmal die
Gasrechnung für Dezember nicht
eingezogen das heißt das führt
tatsächlich zu einer Entlastung von dem
Menschen ist gut das wird die Menschen
die das per Lastschrift monatlich
einziehen lassen dann wird es einfach
nicht wird es einmal nicht angezogen und
das ist schon also in Zwölftel der
Jahresrechnung weil er für einen Monat
diese Summe übernommen wird es gut es
ist Teil dieses entlastungspaketes und
notwendig und dann hat man sich darauf
verständigt in der gastkommission wir
machen neue Tarife die auch spar-anreize
haben die ab März greifen und vorher
geht es nicht und auch in der
strompreisbremse ist die Frage wie kann
ich denn jetzt in so einem
Versorgungsunternehmen die IT so
umändern die Programme so anders
schreiben dass ich neue
verrechnungsmodelle habe und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gerne
beschließen dass das im Januar
stattfindet das ist aber technisch nicht
machbar und das ist das was mich an
diesen Beschluss wirklich nach wie vor
irritiert uns vorsichtig auszudrücken
natürlich ist es richtig die Menschen zu
entlasten und man muss Instrumente
entwickeln dass es die Menschen erreicht
aber das stimmt erwartungsmanagement und
das was dann am Ende gemacht werden kann
nicht mehr überein ich befürchte dass
wir enorme Frustrationen dadurch
hervorrufen weil wir eben nicht die
Instrumente implementieren die umsetzbar
sind sondern weil die Energieversorger
jetzt damit konfrontiert werden ihr
müsst bitteschön in den nächsten Wochen
ein völlig neues Programm
implementieren damit ab 1 Januar ein
ganz neuer Tarif greift und ich sage
Ihnen das geht nicht okay aber das
müsste die Bundesregierung eigentlich
wissen und die Länder haben wir auch
vielfach kommuniziert an die
Bundesregierung an die Länder und im
übrigen an die gaskommission die an der
Stelle sehr klare Vorgaben gemacht hat
die gaskommission hat nämlich gesagt
okay wir verstehen die Garde graspreis
das neue Tarif kann erst im März
stattfinden also machen wir einen
abschlagssystem es gab aus meiner Sicht
einen großen kommunikativen Fehler dass
man diesen Dezember Abschlag Dezember
Abschlag und nicht Winterhilfe genannt
hat weil nämlich jetzt alle gekommen
sind gesagt haben das haben wir ja
vorhin auch von Herrn Wahl gehört naja
dezember ist super was passiert im
Januar und ich meine so kann man
natürlich immer vorgehen dass man sagt
und dann kommt der Februar wir brauchen
zielgerichtete Hilfe für die Leute die
ihre Rechnung nicht bezahlen können das
ist unabdingbar ist absolut notwendig
Verbrauch Unterstützung für die
Wirtschaft damit die tatsächlich auch
über die nächsten Monate kommt aber die
Modelle müssen so sein dass sie
tatsächlich die Menschen auch erreichen
und das ist mit dem die gaskommission
hat gesagt märz und davor müsst ihr
andere Modelle implementieren das hätte
man beim Strompreis auch machen können
hat man sich heute was anderes überlegt
die Diskussion führen wir noch also um
das nochmal klar zu machen die
gaspreisbremse heißt man soll für 80%
des Verbrauchers auf dem die
Abschlagszahlung von September 21 bas
Schritte zahle ich 12 Cent und alles was
da drüber ist genau das habe ich mehr
2022 ist die
genaue Referenz genau ja also der
Verbrauch der im September dieses Jahres
geschätzt wurde ist die Ausgangsbasis
damit die Leute jetzt nicht anfangen
mehr zu heizen oder mehr Gas zu
verbrauchen
für diesen Verbrauch gilt dann quasi für
80% der gedeckelte Preis genau 12 Cent
um bei der strompreisbremse ist es dann
40 Cent auch für 80 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs aber das ist doch
dann ein Anreiz zu sparen das doch dann
erstmal nicht schlecht zu sein ja weil
man die Prämie auch behält egal wie viel
man verbraucht das heißt wenn man nicht
80 also weniger als 80 Prozent
verbraucht bellt man das Geld wählt man
die Prämie das heißt es gibt einen
sparenreiz auch unterhalb der 80 Prozent
das ist wichtig glaube ich um eben in
der ganzen Breite der der Energie
Nachfrage wirklich gefahrenreize zu
setzen das ist gut das ist gut überlegt
glaube ich
was darüber passiert ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass dass man sozusagen statt
dem Deckel vielleicht eher eine Bremse
implementiert dass man sagt irgendwie
also man hat zwischen den 80 Prozent und
dem was darüber kommt Stufen der
Entlastung aber dass man nicht so sofort
sozusagen den Marktpreis
springt weil wir ja nicht wissen wie
sich der Energiepreis der Gaspreis der
Strompreis entwickelt das heißt jenseits
der 80 Prozent kann es wirklich noch mal
zu härten kommen aber erstmal ist gut
dass es sparenreize gibt auch unterhalb
der 80 Prozent ist gut aber es ist
irgendwie kompliziert Freunde ist dass
die auch eine Botschaft die da heute
darüber kam ein sehr kompliziert und wir
sprechen jetzt ja gerade über das Modell
was dann ab kommende März dann
rückwirkend zum Februar vielleicht noch
mehr rückwirkend je nachdem wie die
Gespräche jetzt laufen greifen soll aber
jetzt quasi auch der erste Punkt ist ja
schon kompliziert diese auch wenn das
jetzt einfach klingt die
Abschlagszahlung wird nicht eingezogen
aber die Hälfte der Deutschen lebt zur
Miete in den meisten Mehrfamilienhäusern
gibt es der Zentralheizung da wird die
Abrechnung zentral gemacht und da wird
über die Kosten dieses Jahres erst im
kommenden Jahr quasi abgerechnet das
heißt das was jetzt hier als Entlastung
angekündigt ist wird mancher Mieter erst
im Herbst 2023 überhaupt dann als
Gutschrift auf seiner
Nebenkostenabrechnung zu spüren bekommen
und ich meine dafür sind jetzt neun
Milliarden Euro eingeplant das ist
wirklich das ist viel Geld aber wenn
viele Menschen das gar nicht als
Entlastung empfinden weil im Dezember
bei ihnen überhaupt nichts passiert dann
ist das einfach wie Frau André schon
zurecht sagte da geht im Moment
kommunikativ einfach vieles drunter und
drüber und das nicht gut gelöst und es
hilft nicht den Menschen die bei ihnen
in die Beratungsstellen kommen und sagen
ich kann meine Rechnung nicht bezahlen
also das mache ich mit denen das ist ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt ich kann das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen wieso
Hauseigentümer
und Mieter unterschiedlich behandelt
werden denn die Hauseigentümer die
bekommen ja tatsächlich diese
Abschlagszahlung diese Soforthilfe im
Dezember bis Ende Dezember und warum die
Mieter das dann nicht in demselben Monat
bekommen können oder bis sicher bekommen
können das ist das ist nicht gut weil
sie bekommen es ja virtuell also sie
bekommen
es eben später erst ausgezahlt die einen
Willkommens ausgezahlt die anderen nicht
wir haben diese beiden großen
Verbrauchergruppen ungefähr gut die
Hälfte der Deutschen wohnt zur Mieter
und zehn Prozent auch nicht schlimm
im Moment ja auch noch relativ moderate
Vorauszahlungen eben weil die hohen
Kosten also meistens wenn die
Vorauszahlung erst dann angehoben wenn
eine Abrechnung stattgefunden hat
spricht der Kosten Hammer kommt für die
Mieter wahrscheinlich erst im nächsten
Jahr und diese beiden großen Gruppen
unterschiedlich zu behandeln ist nicht
richtig und ist auch nicht klug ja
also das ich glaube das Grund nachdem
wir merken ja schon wie wir jetzt hier
so Stocken geraten was gilt wann und wer
wird jetzt eigentlich wann entlastet und
müsste entlastet werden das ist halt
einfach keine klare einfache
verständliche Entlastung im Sinne von im
September gab es diese 300 Euro
energiepreispauschale da kann man jetzt
drüber diskutieren ob es da vielleicht
500 Euro 1000 Euro gestaffelt nach
Einkommen man das noch mal hätte machen
sollen aber das wäre auf jeden Fall eine
sehr viel spürbarere Entlastung gewesen
und dann hätten wir auch die ganze
Diskussion über Ölheizung und
holzpelletheizungsbesitzer nicht als
jetzt dieses komplizierte Modell wo dann
irgendwas auf Abrechnungen zu einem
Zeitpunkt im nächsten Jahr verrechnet
wird und
dann doch beim vielen Menschen fürchte
ich der Eindruck hängen bleibt was
bekomme ich eigentlich das wäre ihnen
auch lieber gewesen Einmalzahlungen
wenn sie es besser gefunden gerechter
also vor allem wäre es vom
auszahlungsweg es wäre eine monetäre
Entlastung gewesen die die Menschen
gehabt hätten sie hätten einfach Geld
gehabt im Dezember im Januar im Februar
wie man das gestaltet hätte und
tatsächlich gab es ja mal das
energiegeld diese 300 Euro die zumindest
versteuert wurden also da war eine
gewisse soziale
Komponente drin und was wir jetzt
erleben ist dass wir über einen Abschlag
reden weil Gas wahrscheinlich über einen
Abschlag bei Strom der übernommen werden
soll über zwei neue Tarifmodelle die mit
sparenreize haben die kann man auch
implementieren dann geht es noch um die
Frage was ist mit Öl was ist mit
Heizpellets mit Holzpellets dann geht es
um die Frage mieter Vermieter am Ende
vom Tag ist es wirklich ein ziemliches
Durcheinander und ein energiegeld das
kennen wir schon das ist ein
eingeschwungener Weg das einfach noch
mal zu machen und zu sagen dass es jetzt
der ihr bekommt noch mal ein energiegeld
ausgezahlt als direkte Entlastung und im
März stehen zwei Bremsen nämlich bei
Strom und bei Gas das können die
Energieversorger gewährleisten dann wäre
es in sich stimmiges System gewesen aber
wo ist das Problem bei diesem
energiegeld man hat damals schon gemerkt
man erreicht die Rentner und
Rentnerinnen nicht und die Studierende
nicht aber wo ist das Problem da
wiederum dahinter die Regierung hätte
schon lange sich mal gedanken zu machen
können wie wenn eigentlich
auszahlungspfade organisiert damit diese
Menschen erreicht werden die haben
Koalitionsvertrag ein klimagergeld
stehen also da war der Plan wir werden
alle Menschen erreichen mit einem
Klimagerät dann hätte ich doch in dem
Moment anfangen müssen einen
auszahlungspfad für genau dieses zu
entwickeln das würde uns jetzt so vieles
leichter machen und sie haben Recht die
es ist unfassbar kompliziert je mehr man
in die Details reingeht umso
komplizierter wird ja vor allem dieser
über diesen auszahlungspfad also wie
kann der Staat jedem Bürger
unkompliziert Geld überweisen reden wir
seit drei Jahren oder seit zweieinhalb
Jahren nämlich seit Beginn der
corona-pandemie da trat dieses Problem
zum ersten Mal auf und es wurde gesagt
das ist ja irgendwie blöd wir haben die
Familienkasse kennt die Bankverbindung
der und die Rentenversicherung die der
Rentner und so staffelt sich das dann
durch aber es gibt keine zentrale Stelle
die sagen könnte wir überweisen jetzt
Geld an die Bürger deswegen müssen wir
die Energieversorger machen das könnte
man gelbster eine Möglichkeit dass man
das so regelt dass man alle Bürger
erreicht die muss man schaffen die gibt
es nicht offenbar gibt es sie nicht zu
Überraschung fast alle Akteure gibt es
keine Möglichkeit an alle Haushalte was
auszuzahlen da fragt man sich Einser
also abziehen geht immer ganz gut aber
aber auszahlen geht geht offenbar nicht
ich verstehe auch warum es vielleicht
hier und da nicht geht aber diese
Möglichkeit muss man schaffen wir
müssten die kann man doch erreichen die
kann man erreichen die muss man auch
erreichen die die technische Umsetzung
daran habe zum Teil und das ist der
Punkt den ich am Anfang angesprochen
habe wir sind in vielen Dingen nicht
weit genug wirklich
kluge Instrumente wirklich zu
implementieren also wir erwarten von der
Wirtschaftspolitik die Umsetzung kluger
Politik und scheitert an der an der
Umsetzung also handwerklich sind diese
Instrumente manchmal auch schlecht
gemacht wir haben es bei der gasumlage
gesehen aber es gibt natürlich auch
nicht irgendwie dass man die Einführung
die Wirtschaftspolitik aufschlägt auf
Seite 78 findet man jetzt die die Liste
an Instrumenten die uns jetzt hilft so
ist es natürlich nicht aber wir müssen
langsam lernen wie Sie sagen Frau Löhr
uns daran zu gewöhnen dass wir solche
also schnell lernen
könnte man das ja auch ganz
unbürokratisch altmodisch machen wie das
zum Beispiel in Frankreich oder in
Österreich geschieht die haben Sex an
die Bürger verschickt also eben weil sie
auch nicht von jedem die Bankverbindung
kennen aber dann wurden eben per
postschecks verschickt die Bürger dann
einlösen konnten bei ihren Energie
machen niemand würde verstehen was es
die Entlastungswirkung was das zahle ich
was bekommen welchen einsparanreiz habe
ich also ist alles alles völlig unklar
wann es kommt wie stark es wirkt und es
geht jetzt darum um zweierlei einmal die
die Stabilisierung der der Situation die
Entlastung wirklich planbar sozusagen an
alle Haushalte zu geben aber natürlich
auch mit Unternehmen und die sprechen
wir sicherlich gleich noch und diese
einsparanreize zu geben und und beides
beide sozusagen Effekte die wir die wir
erzielen wollen sind aus meiner Sicht
mit diesem Paket relativ unklar
geblieben
bleiben direkt Geld sind ja andere
Staaten schon viel weiter als wir sie
haben ein Beispiel genannt die USA haben
das schon gemacht die haben solche Geld
da schon ausgezahlt direkt die
Österreicher machens dass wir das immer
noch nicht machen können ist ein
Armutszeugnis die Regierung hat es
versprochen im Koalitionsvertrag und es
sind ganz ganz keinerlei eine Schritte
die in die Richtung gehen der
Finanzminister hat vor ein paar Wochen
gesagt er braucht 18 Monate bevor das
umsetzbar ist das ist natürlich viel zu
lang und wir sehen jetzt gerade dass wir
genauso ein Instrument brauchen wir
werden dieses Instrument auch für andere
Dinge zum Beispiel für die Rückführung
der CO2 Bepreisung wollen wir das haben
aber auch jetzt wäre es super gewesen
wenn wir das Instrument jetzt schon
gehabt hätten haben wir nicht gut jetzt
leben wir also mit diesem
zweitbesten System und es ist ja nicht
so dass mit dieser Preis Bremse die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vollständig
entlastet werden sondern es wird dir nur
die Spitze gekappt und wir müssen die
die Verbraucher Verbraucher müssen ja
noch verglichen mit letztem Jahr müssen
sie ja auch mit dieser Bremse immer noch
ein doppelten Preis bezahlen das heißt
ihre Rate ist doppelt so hoch wie vorher
das heißt der einspar- sage ich mal so
der ist voll da und der anspareinreiz
ist ja und der ist auch jetzt schon da
der ist der spürbar weil wir sehen dass
die Industrie aber auch die privaten
Haushalte und die kleinen Unternehmen
sparen aktuell erheblich das hat
sicherlich auch was mit Kommunikation zu
tun ganz viele die Regierung sie
wahrscheinlich wir haben es gesagt bitte
spart immer wieder und das wird man
wiederholen müssen weil es natürlich
nicht reicht wenn wir im Oktober mit
einem warmen Monat gut über die Runden
gekommen sind sondern es wird die
nächsten Monate und Sie haben Recht wir
müssen selbstverständlich auch jetzt
schon am nächsten Winter denken Winter
wenn wir gar nicht wissen ob unsere
gaspeicher noch gefüllt sind und dann
schauen wir noch mal jetzt das waren
jetzt die Privathaushalte schauen wir
aber auch mal auf die Unternehmen die ja
auch entlastet werden sollen Frau André
die großen also große Industrie Betriebe
sollen dann auf 70 sollen Verbrauch von
70 Prozent der soll halt eben dann
gedeckelt sein und mit 7 Cent pro
Kilowattstunden reicht das für die und
Unternehmen wenn ich es richtig jetzt so
verstanden habe korrigieren Sie mich
fand ich das was ja genau also das haben
Sie richtig verstanden das ist das
tatsächlich das Ergebnis der
gaskommission wo sich ja auch die
Industrieverbände die energieverbände
also
Vertreter der Industrie und Vertreter
der Energiewirtschaft mit Wissenschaft
zusammen darauf verständigt haben und es
gab natürlich sehr große Anforderungen
aus der Industrie der Bundeskanzler hat
mal einen industriestrompreis von vier
Cent in den Raum gestellt der war nun
nicht abbildbar aber mit diesen mit
diesem Beispiel geht es jetzt sicher in
die richtige Richtung und auch hier gilt
natürlich sparanreiz also das ist schon
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt dass wir auch
die Anreize zum Sparen geben müssen im
übrigen auch
Verständnis dass die Preise das in
Vorkriegsniveau nicht erreichen können
also deswegen wird man sich in einen das
was immer so unter diesem new normal
läuft wenn uns eine neue Normalität
angewöhnen müssen was Energie kostet und
deswegen ist es sparen noch mal umso
wichtiger oder dass ich nicht verbrauche
muss ich auch nicht bezahlen aber aus
dieser Industrie ist jetzt da ein
deutlicher Schritt gegangen worden der
zu Entlastung beitragen kann
nichtsdestotrotz steht unsere Industrie
im erheblichen Wettbewerb mit anderen
Ländern die viel günstiger Energie
anbieten können als wir und das muss an
anderer Stelle dann kompensiert werden
oder auch gibt es ja auch verschiedene
Ideen die da in den Raum gestellt werden
aber es ist notwendig hier der Industrie
deutlich zu helfen das können wir aber
nicht dauerhaft machen und wir wissen
auf der Angebotsseite wirklich für eine
Bestätigung sorgen das Angebots für eine
Versorgungssicherheit auch für eine
Bezahlbarkeit wenn nämlich die Erwartung
nicht gegeben ist und das sehen wir bei
vielen Unternehmen dann werden
Investitionen nicht nur hier oben
sondern auch verlagert die Erwartung ist
in USA haben wir dauerhaft günstigere
Bedingungen gerade für die
energieintensive Industrie also das ist
wir können das sozusagen nicht über
Subventionen vielleicht ein paar Monate
abfedern aber wir müssen uns dringend
Gedanken machen über die Angebotsseite
wie können wir wirklich diese
Energiewende jetzt ohne Gas was ja
sozusagen eine wichtige
Brückentechnologie war also alle
Energiesysteme in Deutschland waren
darauf ausgerichtet am Ende mit mit
Erdgas als Brückentechnologie
voranzukommen das ist gescheitert das
wird nicht mehr gehen deshalb müssen wir
uns dringend über angebotsseitige
Maßnahmen unterhalten kann mit genau
diese Übung nicht richtig
nur sagen es ist mit russischem Gas also
was was ungefähr die Hälfte unseres
gasimportes ausgemacht hat ich will nur
wir sind nicht bei Null aber ich bin
eigentlich damit man muss sich da raus
investieren man kann nicht auf Dauer an
subventionieren gegen solche Preise und
man muss auf der Angebotsseite neu
justieren aber so dass wir ganz ohne Gas
in der Zukunft und ohne Erdgas in den
nächsten Jahren
von der Ökobilanz her natürlich
irgendwie
das wird auch nicht gehen also das sind
jetzt alles temporäre Maßnahmen aber das
Energiesystem von Grund auf die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen soll
ist eines der Abonnenten
geht es glaube ich darum wirklich jetzt
zumindest wie Dauer der Krise alle alle
angebotsmöglichkeiten irgendwie mit in
Betracht zu ziehen das wissen wir gerade
der Strommarkt ist durchaus durchaus
kompliziert also wir haben eine
Grundlast die wir die wir haben wir
haben Spitzen die wir abfedern müssen
also Atomenergie hilft nicht in jeder
Hinsicht aber es hilft natürlich hier
und da auch die Verstromung von Erdgas
zu vermeiden und soweit alle alle Themen
die ja auch lange bekannt sind und dass
die Strompreise in Deutschland besonders
hoch waren ist ja auch nichts neues das
war es auch Ukraine Krieg schon so im
Vergleich zu anderen Ländern also volle
wie kann man da ja die Industrie weiter
stützen ja ich denke das ist so was wir
gerade angesprochen haben das
Energieangebot ist also jetzt eine sehr
wichtige Stellschraube es muss erhöht
werden und neben den Atomkraftwerken
wird wahrscheinlich auch wenn Herr
Habeck das nicht gerne hört wird diese
Fracking Diskussion weitergehen ob wir
nicht in Deutschland riesige Gasvorräte
in Schiefer Gesteinsschichten die wir
heben könnten sowie die Amerikaner das
machen das ist hier nicht erwünscht
bislang es gibt überall
Bürgerinitiativen wo das mal versucht
wurde aber diese Diskussion werden wir
nicht wegkriegen weil das wie Sie
richtig sagen es ist schon so ein
bisschen bizarr dass wir jetzt Fracking
Gas aus Amerika das eben sehr günstig
ist jetzt zu hohen Kosten und mit einer
schlechten Ökobilanz über den Atlantik
hierher schaffen aber selber unsere
Kapazitäten da nicht nutzen wollen also
ich denke das ist schon quasi auch der
Punkt der jetzt über die Krise
hinausgeht wie soll die deutsche
Industrie langfristig wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und die günstigen Energiepreise
von denen viele Unternehmen in den
vergangenen Jahren eben profitiert haben
klar sie werden steigen aber es muss
irgendwie in einem Verhältnis sein zu
dem was in anderen Ländern üblich ist
weil sonst haben wir hier langfristig
ein Problem
was ja eigentlich zur Zeit verrückt ist
dass der deutsche Staat 200 Milliarden
Euro ausgibt um den Energiepreis günstig
zu halten das ist kurzfristig vollkommen
korrekt aber was machen wir denn in
einem Jahr in zwei Jahren in fünf Jahren
so und das heißt wir haben ja in den
letzten 10 20 Jahren eigentlich im
Ganzen oder in weiten Teilen des Landes
verpasst genau diese Situation zu ändern
das heißt wir haben verpasst uns von den
fossilen Energien zu trennen oder
teilweise zu trennen die zu vermindern
die Importe zu vermindern und die
erneuerbaren Energien auszubauen
Heizungstausch zu machen in den Häusern
weg von der Gasheizung hinzu Heizung mit
erneuerbaren Energien und die
energetische Gebäudesanierung das
Predigen wir seit Jahren
kommt nicht voran so das sind aber genau
die Faktoren die verhindern würden hätte
man die vor 10 20 Jahren schon umgesetzt
dass wir jetzt zu abhängig gewesen sind
wären vom Gas und dann hätten wir uns
diese 200 Milliarden diese 200
Milliarden Euro sparen können wenn wir
sie vorher vielleicht sinnvoller
investiert hätten
wir aber jetzt nach vorne denken damit
wir nicht in 5 Jahren wieder da sind wo
wir jetzt sind und wieder diese
kurzfristigen Maßnahmen die wir
eigentlich gar nicht wollen aber die
vielleicht jetzt brauchen müssen das ist
ja das was sie am Anfang auch sagen dann
die genau die falsche Botschaft das
immer wenn der Krise kommt kommt der
Staat und zahlt und ist es nicht und auf
der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt so
viele Krisen und die alle ja auch
miteinander verbunden sind auf einer Art
dass es vielleicht mal wichtig wäre den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern klar zu machen
es geht eben nicht so weiter auch wenn
der Bundespräsident sagt wir müssen uns
bescheiden aber so richtig geht es ja
dann doch nicht und ich sag mal die
Handlungsspielräume werden ja auch nicht
nicht größer sondern die werden enger
mit der Krise also die Möglichkeiten
jetzt einzuspringen der Staat als der
große
Versicherer von von großen Risiken dass
das wird nicht nicht ewig gehen und wir
müssen sozusagen und das ist ja die
Botschaft wir haben ja die Krisen nicht
deshalb weil wir die Transformation zu
mutig angegangen sind sondern weil wir
sie zu langsam gemacht haben wir werden
ja froh wenn wir in vielerlei Hinsicht
weiter werden das hätte uns ja geholfen
so und und das muss doch sozusagen die
Botschaft sein auch an die Politik nicht
nur ob das jetzt wir reden irgendwie
monatelang gekostet ist 49 oder ist
nicht 79 auch in Ordnung das ist nicht
unwichtig das will ich nicht sagen aber
es ist doch im Sinne des Problems keine
Lösung sondern wir müssen doch echte
Lösungen erzeugen wir müssen das
Energiesystem die Versorgungssicherheit
irgendwie ernsthaft angehend das ist
doch die die Aufgabe oder bis jetzt
irgendwie ein bisschen teurer ist nicht
ernsthaft angegangen oder wer geht es
nicht ernsthaft an
also hoffentlich ändert sich das aber
ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass jetzt
ich meine wir haben in der Pandemie
darüber gesprochen wir bräuchten das wir
bräuchten diese diese
Digitalisierung die
it-seitigen Umsetzungsmöglichkeiten und
und wir haben sie nicht so und und diese
Krise wird ja auch nicht die letzte sein
also muss doch muss doch jetzt endlich
sozusagen hier an an dieser Stelle
Fortschritt gemacht werden das ist die
Seite der Politik wie sieht's denn jetzt
wenn sie sagen von Seiten der Wirtschaft
sie schaffen das auch nicht dass jetzt
alles umzusetzen also wo haben Sie denn
Sachen nicht schnell genug gemacht
also ich habe gesagt wir schaffen nicht
Programm zu programmieren weil es
einfach seine Zeit dauert nur um das
noch mal deutlich zu machen und da wir
von einem Massenmarkt sprechen und von
40 Millionen Verträgen kann sich
ungefähr jeder vorstellen dass das durch
das eine größere Anstrengung wäre aber
bei der Frage der Versorgungssicherheit
ist es völlig klar der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien muss in einem
Tempo in einem Maße zunehmen wie wir es
noch nicht kennen und wie wir aber ein
eine Gesellschaft dafür gewinnen müssen
dass wir das machen und auf der anderen
Seite sämtliche Restriktionen abbauen
was Genehmigungen angeht was Flächen
Verfügbarkeiten angeht was Material
angeht was Fachkräfte angeht und das
Schöne ist doch wir haben ja gesehen
dass es geht also wir haben jetzt diese
lng-terminals in Wilhelmshaven in einem
Tempo aufgebaut wie sich das keiner
hätte vorstellen können dass das in
Deutschland geht und warum haben wir das
gesehen
weil bis zur letzten Amtsstube alle
davon überzeugt waren dass wir das jetzt
machen müssen und dieses
Grundverständnis das brauchen wir in
Deutschland das ist bis in die letzte
amtsstufe rein klar ist wir machen das
jetzt wir weisen die Flächen aus wir
bauen Windparks wir bringen PV auf die
Dächer wir machen PV Freifläche und dann
haben wir den einen Teil und der andere
Teil ist und da bin ich bei Fracking
dass ich höre die Debatte sie sie fängt
ja auch wieder an ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass Fracking uns kurzfristig
überhaupt nichts hilft in Deutschland
weil es sehr viele Jahre dauern wird bis
wir es aufbauen ich bin mir aber ganz
sicher dass wir Moleküle brauchen werden
also wir werden ein Gas brauchen
natürlich haben wir noch Gas
import-länder die nach Deutschland
Erdgas liefern die sich im Augenblick
sehr viel Geld von uns bekommen
Niederlande Norwegen und USA aber die
Zukunft liegt im Wasserstoff und diese
Frage wie schaffen wir es in Deutschland
eine wasserstoffindustrie aufzubauen da
würde ich da würde ich Kraft rein
investieren da würde ich Engagement rein
investieren durch die Forschung rein
investieren es gibt viele Initiativen
bundesweit die genau dieser Frage
nachgehen wie schaffen wir die
elektrolyseure aufzubauen wie schaffen
wir die Leitungen was machen wir mit
power-to Gas also dass ich aus Strom
dann Gas mache wie nutze ich die
vorhandene erneuerbare Energie das ist
aus unserer Sicht die Zukunft die
Erneuerbaren sind im Zentrum wasserstoff
ist der Partner und dazwischen bräuchte
die sehen unabdingbar das ganze muss von
A nach B kommen wir haben im Moment Netz
also das page Kosten das sind Kosten die
müssen die fallen an weil irgendwo zwar
Strom oder Energie generiert wird aber
die wo ganz anders gebraucht wird dann
müssen Netz Engpässe überwunden werden
von 13 Milliarden Euro dieses Jahr weil
am Ende der Netzausbau nicht so
vorangeht wie wir ihn brauchen und das
ist die Kraftanstrengung wo wir hin
müssen erneuerbare netzausbauwasserstoff
da liegt die Zukunft und eben eine
Änderung in den Amtsstuben so wenn ich
Sie richtig
ja und zwar bis in die letzte Amtsstube
ja wobei es ja noch nicht mal innerhalb
der Bundesregierung da wirklich
Einigkeit gibt also wenn es jetzt um das
Thema planungsbeschleunigung geht wie
werden wir schneller und digitaler das
klappt jetzt bei den lng-terminals gut
bei den Windrädern gibt es da auch noch
durchaus jetzt einige Bemühungen aber
bei allem anderen was wir wo wir
schneller werden wollen gibt es dann
schon wieder Streit zwischen dem
Wirtschaft im Verkehrs dem
Umweltministerium darf der Umweltschutz
der Naturschutz Vogelschutz leiden wenn
wir jetzt Bauvorhaben schneller
vorantreiben also schon da zeigt sich
zeigen sich einfach die
Interessenskonflikte die es in der
Gesellschaft als Ganzes natürlich auch
gibt und das ist immer
die einen treiben die anderen Bremsen
das ist glaube ich das wird sehr schwer
da jetzt mehr temposition vielleicht
daran dass die große Botschaft noch
nicht so ganz angekommen ist oder von
der Politik nicht so formuliert in den
letzten Jahren nicht auch von der
Politik nicht ganz so deutlich gemacht
wurde dass das einfach eine Veränderung
mit sich bringt also mein Eindruck ist
bislang immer so alle sind irgendwie
dafür und Energiewende an sich ist was
gut ist aber sobald es dann halt konkret
wird sobald das Windrad in meinem dann
gibt es halt ein Problem und dann gibt's
die Bürgerinitiative und dann wird sich
dagegen gewehrt und ich glaube diese
Botschaft es wird es werden sich Dinge
verändern und das werden halt auch Dinge
teurer werden auch das also es wird die
Frage ist ob sie immer für alle gleich
teurer werden müssen das wäre auch noch
mal eine Frage an sehr engecke also in
dieser
gerechtigkeitsaspekt inwieweit spielt
der genug eine Rolle wer eigentlich
entlastet wird
es ist natürlich
steht außer Frage dass die Haushalte mit
geringem Einkommen dass die natürlich
zuerst und besonders entlastet werden
müssen weil die sind ja diejenigen die
im Zweifel die Rechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen können die müssen wir nicht auf
irgendwas anderes verzichtet sondern da
müsste der Schwerpunkt hingesetzt werden
es gibt auch einige Maßnahmen die das
speziell zum Beispiel bei weiteren des
wohngeld ist noch eine Maßnahme zu
nutzen den Heizkostenzuschuss die gehen
in die Richtung aber insgesamt ist die
Streuung zu groß gewesen ja insgesamt
ist das zu wenig zielgerichtet gewesen
das musste
verbessert werden was auch noch fehlt
ist was machen wir denn mit denjenigen
die jetzt zwar eine finanzielle
Unterstützung kriegen die aber trotzdem
ihre Gasrechnung nicht bezahlen können
das machen wir denn ne dann safranträge
ja weil die die die die Unternehmen
können das auch nicht bezahlen die sind
auch kurz vor der Pleite ja und rennen
wir dann in die Sperren rein und dafür
hat die Bundesregierung oder heute auch
die die auch die Bundesländer haben
darauf überhaupt keine Antwort gegeben
und das ist noch ein wichtiger Punkt der
muss nachgebessert werden dass
diejenigen die wirklich nicht zahlen
können dass die trotzdem die Energie
bekommen das heißt wir brauchen einen
abgebaut wir brauchen eine Moratorium
für sperren und da muss die Regierung
nachbessern sehen sie auch so
ich sehe das so dass wir halt für ihre
Energie ja natürlich da ist eine
Leistung geliefert worden die muss
irgendwo bezahlt werden also muss und da
sind wir ja auch sehr einig da muss dann
der Staat also ich kann doch nicht
irgendeinem energieversorge sagen
deshalb Pech gehabt nein dann zahlt er
halt einer nicht und was wir arbeiten da
haben wir uns ja gemeinsam auch noch mal
an die Regierung gewendet das notwendige
ist dass man wirklich im Vorfeld und
sehr frühzeitig auch mit diesen Menschen
weil das sind oft multiple Probleme als
nur in Anführungsstrichen die
Möglichkeit nicht mehr zu bezahlen
sondern da stellen sich größere
Fragestellungen also kann man mit
Schuldnerberatung mit unterstütz
Bremsleistungen mit dem Jobcenter mit
wem auch immer schnell und natürlich
auch mit dem Energieversorger schnelle
Ansprache bei den Leuten wo klar ist da
wird es wirklich Knirsch aber dass wir
verhindern müssen dass es sperren gibt
ja dass die Menschen ihre Wohnung nicht
mehr warm und ihr abbekommen und ihr
Licht nicht mehr anmachen können das ist
nur eine gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung da
bin ich wirklich einig und muss ein
bisschen aufpassen welche Botschaft man
sendet ich könnte mir gut vorstellen
dass man zum Beispiel eine Lösung findet
die Abschlagszahlung oder die Rechnung
die im Vorjahr gezahlt werden konnte
dass die wenigstens gezahlt wird weil
wir nicht in so eine denke reinkommen
wollen ist alles kostenlos jetzt ja also
muss ja aber das muss ich ausbalancieren
also in der quasi moralischen und auch
notwendigen Zielsetzung bin ich da
völlig einig aber im Detail oder in der
Umsetzung liegen dann wirklich
Schwierigkeiten
da bin ich stimmig überein da brauchen
wir noch Antworten aus der Politik die
dieses auch lösen weil wir da schon
erhebliche Probleme auch bei uns in den
in den Kundencentern sehen dass Menschen
tiefen Verzweiflung weil sie sagen ich
kann es nicht mehr bezahlen die
theoretische Antwort gibt es ja
zumindest im beschlussspapier das ist
der sogenannte härtefallfonds aber auch
da sind die Begriffe halt noch sehr
schwammig es ist von einer unzumutbaren
Belastung die Rede wenn der greifen soll
wo dann die Frage ist wie definieren wie
wird das definiert und wer wird das
definieren wann eine solche Belastung
vorliegt also das darüber gab es ja
heute nicht nur einigkeiten
wo man sich aber dann einig wurde war
das 49 euro-ticket als Nachfolge für das
9 Euro Ticket und das 9 euro-ticket
hatte war ja ein Erfolg weil viele weil
viele ist genommen haben die Frage ist
haben sie wirklich dafür auf ihr Auto
verzichtet dass die andere Frage dafür
ist das das 49 Euro Ticket ist das
sozusagen der Einstieg in eine gute neue
Verkehrspolitik wo sie sagen das macht
Sinn ja ich denke es ist ein mutiger
mutiger Schritt ein unkonventionelles
Mittel vielleicht was auch gut geklappt
hat das ist sehr gut angenommen worden
ich glaube es besteht auch der Breite
Wille das ist gibt das ist
Nachfolgemodell gibt ich halte es für
richtig es hat wir viele Fragen auf das
will ich gar nicht gar nicht bestreiten
aber ich denke der Einstieg in die
mobilitätswende die ja sozusagen nicht
losgelöst betrachtet werden kann von der
Energiewende ist das ist das richtig
sozusagen
Angebote zu schaffen günstiger Angebote
die eben auch ein Anreiz geben dann
umzusteigen auf den öffentlichen
Personennahverkehr ich finde man kann
das machen es ist wie gesagt wirft
Fragen auf aber von der von der
Grundidee ist es okay wenn man es wird
sicherlich gucken die die
Verkehrsverbünde sind natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich aufgestellt das ist auch
eine Frage der Finanzierung die man noch
mal sozusagen im Nachgang natürlich sich
anschauen muss was kann der Bund
finanzieren was tun die Länder was was
kann sozusagen der Verkehrsbetrieb vor
Ort finanzieren aber dass wir daran
müssen ist ja völlig unstrittig Berlin
hat ja jetzt angefangen ab Oktober das
schon für 29 anzubieten Herr Engelke
sind 49 Euro ist das zu teuer für viele
Menschen für viele Menschen ist es zu
teuer wir hätten
als Nachfolge tatsächlich in 29
euro-ticket gewünscht weil das einfach
noch mal für viele eben bezahlbarer ist
und
zusätzlich wünschen wir uns auch anstatt
dieser Pendlerpauschale die auch viel
Geld kostet ein mobilitätsgeld wo dann
wirklich Mobilität bezahlt wird und
weniger das Auto fahren
aber im Prinzip richtig dass man jetzt
eine deutschlandbreite richtig ist ein
Schritt in die richtige Richtung und man
müsste jetzt noch mal gucken ob es gibt
ja einen einzelnen Bundesländer einzelne
verbündet die das günstige anbieten das
heißt es geht und das wird hätten wir
uns jetzt für das ganze
deutschlandticket gewünscht aber dann
kaufe ich mir in Berlin in 29 Euro
Ticket
fordern durch ganz
deutschlandverbünde gemeint aber ich
kann eben mit einem in Berlin gekauften
Ticket auch in Köln den Bus benutzen ja
aber dann kann ich doch in Berlin eins
für 29 kaufen nee das gilt ja nur in
Berlin das geht nur eine Übergangslösung
für drei Monate die nur in Berlin Geld
dann mal gucken wie das so funktioniert
aber der grundsätzliche Charme des 49
Euro Tickets ist dass man es versteht
also dass man das jetzt anders als die
gaspreisbremse und die Abschlagszahlung
man auch immer sie dann kommt es ist ein
einfaches verständliches Modell man
kauft ein Ticket für 49 Euro kann er mit
den öpnvern ganz Deutschland benutzen
man muss aber dafür ein Abo abschließen
man muss ein Abo abschließen das ist
richtig aber es soll monatlich kündbar
sein also ja schaffte Entlastung auch
vor dem Hintergrund der Inflation
natürlich Mobilität Verkehr hat relativ
großes Gewicht im Warenkorb das heißt es
ist eine spürbare Entlastung das ist
klar kommunizierbar anders als
Instrument und das ist natürlich ein
wesentlicher Grund auch für die für die
Zielgerichtetheit sozusagen von
Instrumenten für die dass man es
versteht dass man weiß wo man spart und
was man damit tun kann und insofern ist
das glaube ich ein
sinnvolles Instrument das ist ja
interessant dass das was ist was bleibt
heute von dieser
Konferenz ist vor allen Dingen das 49
euro-ticket deshalb noch mal vielleicht
die Frage zu dem was sie eigentlich
wichtiger ist im Gas und Strom wo sie
auch viel mehr Geld geht Frau André
hätte man das wirklich leichter haben
können
einfacher ja ich also ich ich sehe zwei
grundsätzliche Probleme das eine ist man
kann solche Rechnungen nicht ohne den
Wirt machen und man muss wirklich die
die es umsetzen müssen fragen was könnt
ihr leisten und das geht zu dem zweiten
Problem über das ist die Frage von
erwartungsmanagement ich habe wirklich
tiefe Sorge dass wir jetzt in eine
Erwartung reinkommen jetzt wird sofort
Strom und Gas günstig bzw ich muss wenig
dafür bezahlen oder ich krieg einen
neuen Vertrag und was passiert am Mitte
November müssen das ist quasi selbst
vorgeschrieben die Energieversorger die
Preiserhöhungen für Januar oder den
neuen Tarif für Januar ankündigen der
wird wie es Amen in der Kirche höher
sein als der Tarif den die Menschen
hatten weil die Energie teurer geworden
ist das heißt wir laufen in eine Phase
rein wo parallel
in einer Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Entlastung die jetzt ankommt
kommuniziert wird und in zwei Wochen
kriegen alle einen Brief da steht drin
aber der Tarif wird übrigens höher also
wird die Kunst sein jetzt schon mal da
rein zu kommunizieren aber für den
Dezember wird euch der Abschlag für Gas
genommen und es ist eine richtige
Maßnahme das war das unter den weil das
andere nicht geklappt hat unter den
Maßgaben also unter den Möglichkeiten
hat man das vernünftig auf dem Weg
gebracht aber dann kann ich nicht
einfach sagen oh das klappt jetzt mache
ich einfach immer eine Schippe drauf ja
beim Abschlag dann da muss man eine
Lösung finden meinetwegen dass man sagt
im Januar noch mal das wird teuer und
dann auch mein wegen februar und bei
Strom aber diese neue Tarifgestaltung
die Preisbremse als solche die kann man
nicht ankündigen für den Januar weil
dann hat man die Versorger nicht gefragt
ob sie es schaffen sie werden es nicht
schaffen und deswegen Abschlag ja eine
direkte Entlastung ist besser aber die
eigentliche Preisbremse kommt später
komplett falsche Ansatz dann hätte man
doch ehrlicherweise von von Anfang an
sagen müssen wir versuchen es über
direkte einkommenstransfers das ist das
ist zielgerichtet wird mir Wissen eines
erreicht
100 Euro deswegen glaube ich es wäre
eigentlich ein kluger Weg zu sagen okay
wir haben schon einmal die Erfahrung mit
dem energiegeld gemacht mit den 300 Euro
jetzt wählen wir diesen Weg noch mal und
dann haben wir im März und dann hat er
mehr Zeit oder die neuen aber apropos
Kommunikation wenn wir jetzt diese
Bremse kriegen es sieht ja so aus egal
ob im Januar Februar oder März aber sie
wird ja kommen was bedeutet das im
Gasbereich für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher wenn ich einen
Durchschnittshaushalt nehme mit einem
durchschnittlichen Verbrauch von 20.000
Kilowattstunden im Jahr das entspricht
so ein drei vier Personenhaushalt
kleines Einfamilienhaus
die müssen auch im nächsten Jahr mit der
Bremse pro Monat etwa 100 Euro mehr
bezahlen als es im letzten Jahr gemacht
haben das ist wichtig das ist die
Erwartung ist das auch ein Punkt Rolle
dass man man hat ja jetzt so das Gefühl
es wird nicht ganz so schlimm ist das
eigentlich dann die komplett falsche
Botschaft weil man man kriegt ja den
alten Preis sozusagen ja ich denke
dieses Gefühl ich teile den Eindruck
dass das gerade vorher was aber
natürlich auch damit zu tun hat dass im
Großmarkt also ein Großhandel die Preise
jetzt tatsächlich auch deutlich gesunken
sind weil das Wetter so warm ist und
hier so wenig Gas verbrauchen
das kann sich dann auch schnell ändern
wenn es wieder wenn es wieder kälter
wird aber ich denke auch dass der
das eben dieses Gießkannenprinzip mit
dem Moment gearbeitet wird eben ein
echtes Problem ist weil es gibt viele
Haushalte in Deutschland für diesen 100
Euro mehr Belastung im Monat auch nicht
erfreulich aber sie sind zu tragen aber
es gibt eben auch Haushalte für die ist
das wirklich hart an der Grenze dessen
was noch möglich ist und dann darf
nichts kaputt gehen zu Hause die
Waschmaschine nicht oder sonst was nicht
und
man ja mein Rat wäre schon dass da
eigentlich mehr als differenziert werden
müsste und sich die Politik stärker auf
diese Haushalte die gerade an der Grenze
sind dessen was finanziell noch zu
leisten ist sich konzentrieren sollte
statt eben jetzt zu versuchen alle ein
bisschen zu beglücken damit jeder das
Gefühl hat dass er doch so ein bisschen
entlastet wird auch die ganz viele
verbrauchen werden ja auch dann
entlassen ja ich meine das war ja auch
mal eine Idee dass man die gasbremse so
setzt dass man jetzt nicht den
Vorjahresverbrauch einen bestimmten
Prozentsatz bezuschusst sondern nur ein
bestimmtes grundkontingent an
Kilowattstunden 5000 Kilowattstunden im
Jahr das wäre auch ein bisschen sozial
gerechter gewesen eben weil dann eine
Obergrenze eingezogen wäre aber hatten
wir wieder das Problem es gibt diese
Daten nicht niemand weiß ob sich hinter
einem Gasanschluss eine die berüchtigte
Villa verbirgt oder eben ein
Mehrfamilienhaus mit zehn Wohnungen und
deswegen ist es halt auch so schwer der
Obergrenzen einzuziehen das ist also es
ist schwer und es wird auch natürlich
sowieso nicht eine klar ganz gerechte
Lösung geben können das ist ja auch
schwierig aber ein bisschen besser als
das was da jetzt heute präsentiert wurde
okay also wir halten fest es ist zu
kompliziert und
man musste ein bisschen längerfristig
schauen absolut der Winter 23 24 ist
steht quasi vor der Tür politisch und
dafür hat man glaube ich zu wenig
gemacht okay vielen dank für die
Diskussion volle Vögel Frau andre und
Herr Engelke und vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen und wenn sie noch mal alles
sehen wollen was die Ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen haben und der Bundeskanzler
dann schauen sie bleiben sie einfach
dran und schauen Sie den Tag mit Thomas
Bade der folgt nämlich jetzt direkt im
Anschluss und da sehen sie das alles
noch mal ausführlich bis dann tschüss
[Musik]